a [ __ ] l'enel e la tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono farisei
bel gioco che stiamo per fare tutti
contenti porca [ __ ] senza questa musica
di sottofondo che sembra che mi debbano
stuprare l'anno da un minuto all'altro
in realtà sarebbe soltanto lampeggiare
delle luci quindi non è che sia tutta
sta suspense però va bene siamo ragazzi
sud di house che è un gioco che mi fa
partire da lì dal giorno 3 da bellissimo
la spesa grafico questo il menu lo ha
delle belle
giorno 3 che io sappia in genere gli
horror ti fanno partire dal giorno 1 o
al giorno 3 prova bene
da per allegro ti giuro che a guardare
twilight i [ __ ] mi erano caduti
ancora prima però è un altro discorso
quella ma come fa a girare così la
macchina ma che macchina è di house a
capalle day one
bene il giorno 3 era scritto così a caso
sale buongiorno è bello l'orsacchiotto e
mi piace anche l'albero fuori non è male
che è veramente c'è un tipo dell'area so
perché quadra mente ci vengono i maroni
che la metà basta è un tipo che andato a
vivere in una casa da solo perché non ci
aveva il cazzo di stare con la famiglia
e con tutti gli altri pene hanno bussato
alla porta quindi andiamo subito ad
aprire mi fa piacere che incamera tua
tieni tutto quanto acceso e allegro
fantasy minchia lights out s'è spenta la
luce ma funziona flashlight hanno
bussato alla porta ragazzi io da un
attimo ci alziamo d'acqua per falsa t
per riscattarmi lega normale
porca eva quanto difficile formazioni
sto gioco maledizione conti perché c'è
un orsacchiotto che mi sta fissando la
faccia in una maniera bab perché lo
tienili l'orsacchiotto schemi la punta
non è che visto cosa è successo mi sono
chiarito ma l'audio ma cosa giorno 2 a
casa c'erano due manager in verde
doveva essere il vento ma che vento poi
cosa mento ma cosa giorno 2 o ma esci
bovary a di casa ha capito quinti faceva
partire dal giorno 3 dove tipo ti
diciamo eva per sei stato tu bastardo
non c'è neanche più gli occhi ma io dopo
queste voci qua continuerei a dormire da
solo è per carità di dio invece del vino
rosso sul muro io lo toglierei ma ti
puoi alzare o poi fare il solo avanti
con questi sette intese rega tipo harry
potter e vedi che a parlare serpente xi
si aprono le porte promesso destino non
ho altro qui lo mi porti anche l'acqua
l'acqua il frigo lo vado a prendere il
giorno 3 uomo globo è bellissimo ma lui
che scrive lo sapevo ma che cazzo scrivi
che è entrato santana dalla porta ma che
cazzo scrive giorno 3 c'è uno che è
entrato nella mia stanza però va bene lo
abbiamo fatto il sesso c'è uno è entrato
nella stanza non l'hai visto sei
rincoglionito spiegami perchè non si è
ancora scappato che problemi sai qual è
il problema di sto ragazzo che verrò io
posso muovermi o fine mi piacevo la
tanto la notte 3 dopo 2 2 notti così
invece di scappare a gambe levate andare
dalla nonna concas notte tre decide di
alzare il culo da letto bene allora
vediamo innanzitutto quella del sugo sul
muro è sparito posso prendere un cestino
un gioco violento questo
[Applauso]
che cazzo
cos'è sta roba cos'è successo è svenuta
una sedia premierebbero interagire ok
non mi interessa o la torcia l'ho
trovata perfetto
chi è che ha messo qua il mio cazzo di
orsacchiotto va bene ecco perfetto la
valigia la prendi ha deciso la roteare
andiamo a [ __ ]
prendiamo un bel treno anni in tibet non
si apre sia premesso non sia posso
nascondermi nell'armadio cazzo è
successo perché non capisco le così
cos'è è la mia ombra [ __ ] come ho
fatto a vedere la mia da dove so dove
sono come sono arrivato qua spiega mi
cosa che gioco di merda non si capisce
niente raga sono finiti in un tubo in un
tunnel da lavori in alto nella seconda
io seguo la scia di merda non segua la
scia di merda facciamo che non segue la
scia di merda è roba dannosa tipo tua
sorella si dice senza impresa ton e se
stai cercando il frigo per portarmi la
bottiglia che non mi hai portato
un'altra volta brutto sola che ti segue
così ma che chi è giunti no no no rialzi
non serio no raga serio cazzo
cambiale ricarica perfetto che culo ma
mi sa che quello di qua io sceso
proposta sta voglia andare di qua perché
mi piace proprio di qua
raga non ho capito perché c'è un tizio
che un tizio perché sono nelle latrine
di casa mia spiegatevi con il problema
perché sto correndo senza la torcia e
pure illumino lamentela sta tenendo in
bocca al tizio lato alla torcia che non
è possibile comunque fisica perfetto ma
promette meglio di tutto il resto del
gioco guarda io io seguo è se non si
sarà permesso
salve buongiorno vedo che anche per lei
una giornata molto felice e molto storta
e potrei chiudere la porta che non sono
mai entry satana pure di qua senza è una
cortesia non lo voglio disturbarlo in
quanto è figo non voglio disturbare la
volevo solo chiederle perché cazzo ci
sono degli smile sui quadri e le cose
perché lei è messo stava guardando un
porno che se fresato mentre ci aveva un
orgasmo regala chi sa che il cazzo sta
guardando e non lo voglio sapere
vabbè usciamo se si può uscire non avevo
dubbi guarda ma non è che c'è una chiave
che perfetto ho trovato una cosa non era
la chiave questo almeno dimmi che cosa
ho preso manie non dice né anche potrà
aver preso anche un preservativo è
successo
cioè mi mi dici che cosa io sono io cosa
sto impressionando il tizio non lo
voglio sapere cosa è successo al tizio
va bene così
l'altro non c'erano gli smile prima qua
non c'era il sangue che ovviamente il
mio quindi fantastico ma proprio la
visuale sulla telecamera frontale o
basta fu poi è diventato così come
l'abbiamo vista sesso ma che cazzo di
gioco ex s cosa succede niente vabbè
adesso sì che ho capito fra perfetto da
lei ragazzi dai usavo che non ho capito
cosa devo fare qua dentro ancora devo
capire dove devo andare cosa è successo
chi è che mi segue
è un buon segno che non è un buon segno
quando sento sto rumore quanto sei bello
perché non hai le gambe zio che problemi
hai almeno siete coerenti non pulite da
una parte non potete neanche dall'altra
perfetto possiamo giocare in quattro
giochiamo tutti a the forest viene anche
tu zio porta anche il morto che giochi
siamo almeno in tre fasce un microfono a
tutti i ragazzi benvenute questo nuovo
video io non ho capito dove stiamo ma
che ci fa qui urbana che brutta cosa e
successo la cedola geraci mela ci cazzo
ma vabbè se mi piglia sto male
il dietro prima cosa sinistra ma c'era
solo un cognome è un [ __ ] pure lui
ho finalmente un posto allegro
hallelujah bellini del modus coppia
perché c'è l'intro di mark player in un
posto così lo sapevo che non era un
gioco serio io che non avevo dubbi
guarda ho finalmente una porta rossa
cazzo come l'aspettavo la porta rossa
del demonio
volevo proprio questa guarda che cazzo
dimmi che se clicchi questo bellissimo
tasto verde diventa tutto di nuovo
illuminato non funziona un cazzo non ha
neanche più retto alla torcia fanta
ragazzo meraviglioso non vedo niente
che cazzo me che clicchi la porta rossa
di satana non andava bene
non lo vedo non so dove
sapevo che volete vedere qual era il
vero di house quello pop ovvero ovvero
vero vero artista cagate flashgames.it
un sito figo dove sotto la categoria
punta e clicca fuga da una stanza escape
e giochi per bambini troviamo di non è
un cazzo per bambini non annuncia biada
non claudia 82 83 25 ai lo fa vj non
esattamente perché questo signore era di
house e quelli erano dei capelli horror
oggi in teoria doveva uscire il terzo
episodio di non ce ne frega un cazzo è
venuto a casa qualcosa
lancio di sarri for what i've done
ma ricordava la ricordavo
e la figlia tutta fuori così che si
conquista la patata zio è capito tutto
ma che cazzo è diventato stupide umida
da da un horror è diventato un video
reaction basta barba
va bene così io sarei stata una roba che
sono dei video veramente pino senso che
abbia mai fatto solo partito con un
horror siamo finiti sul mio canale a
vedere dei video vecchi per è la
nostalgia
però ragazzi è sempre bello fare un
tuffo nel passato perché mi ricordo che
anche se adesso sono così che non è il
massimo della vita è una volta e roero
così che non è il massimo neanche quello
ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto 26 gennaio dell'argomento è un
mi piace anche a pacelli facebook.com
egiziane sensore city siete mi ci
dividiamo prossimo video belle ragazze